It's great to be here in Singapore.
I've been really overwhelmed,
uh,
with the uh,
reception and those he has him that I've observed and all the different venues
that we've been in so far.
So thank you for your interest in the space.
When I would like to hope to do tonight is maybe personalize it,
humanize it a little bit,
and give you an ID had vicariously when it's like to go to space and to
participate in,
in the current chapter of human exploration,
uh,
what we call the international space station.
This is the view they have up there and we're all inspired by that,
right?
We love space.
All of us do.
Uh,
there's,
I don't meet anybody that's not inspired by the vantage point that,
uh,
you have to view it as an example to look back on the earth and see the details
of the earth like this.
In a few minutes,
I'm going to show a video and give me some more examples of,
of a zoomed up,
a detail or a zoomed in detailed of a,
of the earth.
What you can see from this vantage point,
which is the international space station and how many here have seen the space
station fly over?
Quite a few of you.
Good.
The a homework assignment for the rest of you is to,
uh,
is to go get one of those apps that are out there or go to a website on the
Internet,
uh,
that will give you the predictions on when you'd be able to see the,
the,
the space station fly over if you haven't done it.
Those of you that have done it,
you know,
it's very inspiring to be able to see it fly over.
It's the brightest thing in the night sky with the exception of the moon.
And to know that there are people on board currently six crew of six,
which is the standard crew size and international crew.
Uh,
we live in and working up there.
And if you get involved in,
in,
uh,
get on the NASA website and follow the activities along and either the NASA site
or other sites out there that then you get engaged actually with the activities
that are currently going on.
Uh,
and then to see it fly over his is really inspirational.
So I encourage you to do that if you haven't done it before.
Of course,
the challenge here in Singapore,
it is finding a cloudless night,
right when you do see it fly over is uh,
usually right after sun set or right before sunrise when it stark here and the
surface of the earth and the light is still shining on the space station.
Uh,
and it's so bright because of the size of it in those solar rays,
the wings out and the the left and right,
which reflect the Sun's light and make it a bright object.
The unit from the surface of the earth.
The space station is an incredible accomplishment in and of itself.
Uh,
the first element was launched in 1998.
We finished it in 2011.
My first visit there was in 2000.
It was just modules,
a very small,
it was before the first,
uh,
expedition launched to the space station.
We use that term expedition to refer to the crews that go there and live there
for a long period of time.
The standard length of time nowadays is about six months.
Uh,
we launched expedition one in the fall of 2000 and a lot of people around the
world don't realize that since the fall of 2000,
we've had continuous human presence in space.
Uh,
currently a crew of six in the early years.
We had crews of three or two after the Columbia accident,
which of course delayed the,
uh,
the assembly of the space station after the loss of Columbia.
And our friends that were on the crew of the space shuttle was grounded for
about three years.
We had a very limited way to supply the space station without being able to fly
the space shuttle.
Uh,
so we reduced the crew size from three to two.
So my second flight was about halfway through assembly.
During that time when the shuttle was grounded and we were approved to and there
was a six month long flight.
My Russian cosmic not mate and I launched about halfway through that day,
the shuttle started flying again.
Um,
we got added to our crew,
to my rider who had German astronaut,
and then we picked up assembly the space station and then finished it up.
Uh,
when I was there again in 2009 and 10,
it took about a 37,
as I recall,
shuttle flights to assemble the space station and then also support it during
the assembly.
And after that time,
we,
uh,
of course retired the shuttle,
but it accomplished its primary purpose that it was designed for to put up the
space station.
And along with those 37,
a shuttle launches,
uh,
came about 40 Russian launches as well to put up the space station.
So it was a huge effort.
When you think of it,
the number of rocket launches it took to put it up there piece by piece over
many years from 1998 to 2011 and result is what you see here in the screen.
It's very big.
It didn't just appear there.
It took a lot of work and effort piece by piece to put it up.
Uh,
it went together very well.
it's quite an impressive achievement in technology and engineering and
integration at the international level where we had elements of the space
station meet and be integrated the first time,
not on paper,
on paper,
on the ground,
and it was integrated on paper.
But,
uh,
to take a physical components of the space station in integrated minor,
but physically for the first time in space is pretty impressive when you're
launching some elements from the U S and other elements from Russia.
I in Japanese elements from,
from yet another location and designed and all around the world.
So it's quite an accomplishment.
If you could lay the space station on the ground,
it would be bigger than a football field.
If you could put it on a scale and weigh it,
it would weigh almost a million pounds.
So that gives you an idea of the size of the scope of the,
of the assembly of the space station itself,
uh,
on the inside where the crew lives in work,
which is the center of what you see here in the view,
the stack of cylinders,
if you will,
pressurized modules.
Um,
it's has the volume equivalent to about a 5,000 square foot house.
Uh,
so it's very roomy inside,
spread out,
over multiple modules.
The crew of six then is you think we're,
uh,
we're all,
living and working tied in a cluster for six months.
That's not true.
Who we're spread out every day working in different parts of the space station.
We typically gather together for meals and whatnot.
Um,
but it is a huge facility,
a lot of potential ladder,
great history already.
It's got a great operation ongoing right now and it's got a very promising
future,
uh,
with doors that will continue to open to get on board even through things that
were talked about earlier that the produce she talked about in other venues to
get experiments and a new technology onboard the space station.
So it's got a lot of potential,
a lot of applicability for you all here.
The space station itself has it in an orbit inclined to the equator if 51.6
degrees.
So the,
the,
that means as it orbits the earth,
it crosses the equator,
say going from south to north and goes up to 51.6 degrees.
North latitude comes back,
the other side crosses the equator down to 51,
six.
So a latitude,
and then,
and then back up,
uh,
each time it crosses the equator after a one orbit,
the Earth of course in a 24 hour rotation has rotated so that you cross the
equator about 1500 miles or so to the west of the previous orbit.
What that means is it's near ideal orbit,
uh,
to for the longterm to do observations of the earth's surface.
So it's a great platform for those studies.
You see the entire globe,
except for the Poles,
north and south pole.
Um,
and,
and the,
the phasing of the orbit means that over days and weeks you see all those
locations on the earth in different lighting conditions,
day,
night,
different sun angles during daytime,
uh,
you watch weather patterns go by and over weeks and months,
you see seasons go by.
Uh,
so it's a great platform for observing the earth.
Um,
backing up a little bit,
the space shuttle,
I said 37 lunches to uh,
to get anybody here see a space shuttle launch.
Quite a few of you.
Yeah,
it was pretty impressive,
right?
Very humbling to go there.
You're three miles away and then you have the power of the main engines and the
solid rocket boosters that shook your whole body.
[inaudible]
very impressive to see us a space shuttle launch.
Very impressive to see any rocket launch and you're going to go here in a couple
of weeks and see the space x launch down in Florida.
It is a humbling experience to see one of those.
You realize we're reminded when we see that access to space is not easy.
It's a very difficult,
uh,
but when a rocket launches to go to orbit that the,
particularly in low earth orbit,
while we call where the space station is,
you're in orbit and less than nine minutes and then that nine minutes,
you're going 17,500 miles an hour,
that's orbital velocity.
Uh,
roughly think 250 miles above the earth's surface.
That means you are a bit the earth every 90 minutes or 16 times a day.
Uh,
so it's a lot of physics involved.
It is rocket science.
Um,
what I wanted to do now is that when they give you a sense of the rhythm of life
on the space station program by showing you a video that's about 15,
if our tech supports us anyway,
showing you a video that a is about 15 minutes line that highlights the last
year is mission that I was a participant on,
uh,
across,
the time of what we called expedition 47 and 48.
It'll start.
Um,
and at the Baikonur Cosmodrome in Kazakhstan,
which is the location that was developed in the late fifties,
early sixties by the Soviet Union,
the beginning of the space race.
And we launched from the same lunch pad and all crews now rotating on Russian.
So use rockets to the space station lunch and the same launchpad that Yuri
Gagarin launched from the first human in space,
uh,
many over 50 years ago now.
Um,
so a lot of history there.
I'll talk a little bit more later,
perhaps in the Q and a about the international partnership,
uh,
of all of this.
So expedition 47,
48,
uh,
this was a,
as I said,
the last flight I was on last year,
so march of 2016 we completed our training and I was a crude up at two Russian
nuts.
Um,
Alexei and,
uh,
[inaudible].
And uh,
we went down to the Kazak stand from Moscow,
the Moscow region about 12 days prior to lunch.
I spent some time doing her final preparations there in Kazakhstan.
And then,
uh,
they got the rocket on the launch pad two days before lift,
our launch day.
And then we unlaunched morning,
we got in our suits,
took the ride out to the launchpad,
did the traditional way here,
and then got on the elevator to get to the top of the rocket and strap in about
two and a half hours before liftoff.
Uh,
is,
he is coming in through this a hatch.
If you're claustrophobic,
you're in the wrong business.
I get that question a lot.
So none of us are,
uh,
we actually get into the seats on our back in the fetal position and I liken it
to triplets in the womb,
like say old in was the commander of the,
so he is,
that was his daughter's little stuffed animal there that he flew for her as a
souvenir.
We also call it the zero g meter hangs on the string until we get to orbit.
Um,
and then it bounces all over in the video.
And some of you have seen that,
uh,
on,
launches of,
so use takes less than nine minutes to get to orbit just like the space shuttle
after which you're going 70,000,
500 miles an hour or about 25,000 kilometers per hour.
Uh,
and then we set up the rendezvous,
uh,
to rendezvous with the space station less than six hours later after lunch.
This is what the space station looked like as we approached it.
Uh,
and,
uh,
this is what we look like as we approached the space station.
The final moments of approach as after we lined up with this docking port and
then successfully docked,
uh,
after which we did a leak checks between the two vehicles,
got the hatches open and we were welcomed on board,
uh,
by Tim,
Tim and Uri,
Tim Kopra,
American astronaut,
10 peak,
uh,
British astronaut,
the first and today the only British astronaut.
And then you're a millennial Russian Cosmin so that we rounded out the crew of
expedition 47 in annex.
Got Us underway,
uh,
in that,
crew combination of six,
uh,
here's the,
a shot of the inside of the space station.
Here we are in the US segment and going to the u s laboratory into the unity
module,
which is the place that we typically have our crew meals.
So we have our,
all our food there and we gather,
run a typically as a crew of six,
at least a couple times a week.
Other than that,
we're kind of busy a spread to the four winds,
but,
uh,
we tried to do that to maintain crew cohesion.
You can see it's very easy to,
uh,
to move around there.
You just get yourself moving in the right direction,
um,
and get there and then stop.
We had a very busy first few weeks after we had arrived.
It seemed like in every major activity was on a weekend.
We had three supply ships,
uh,
show up the first three weekends we were there.
The first one was a Russian progress and then we had this orbital sciences
sickness,
uh,
bring up,
almost 6,000 pounds of cargo and supplies.
Um,
and then a week later we had a space x dragon show up.
Uh,
and you'll see from after this video that logistically supply in the space
station is a,
is a very,
uh,
intensive activity that's ongoing for,
for obvious reasons and other reasons that maybe aren't so obvious that
particular space x had a unique cargo on board.
It was called the beam module.
[inaudible] is the acronym it stood for or stands for,
the big low experimental activity module.
It's the first inflatable module that we've integrated onto the space station.
So we got it attached to the space station and then a few weeks after that and
we got around to inflating it,
just,
uh,
allowing air from the inside of the,
where we are in the space station into this new module.
And it was designed them too
to,
uh,
to inflate,
to expand and increase its internal volume.
Uh,
and it's a great example of technology development,
uh,
that the space station is intended to be a platform for,
to develop new technologies for future application and inflatable modules can be
there volumetrically efficient to launch under a rocket fairing and then get to
where you need it.
Uh,
so it's a very promising technology.
and here's the moment of celebrating that milestone in our state.
Uh,
last year it'll stay on board the space station for several years because it
proves out it's tech runaways,
Jeff Williams.
We fast forward into June and I,
expedition 47 comes to an end.
We transitioned the expedition 48 we have a,
an old navy tradition up there where we ring the bell for the change of command.
So I took command from Tim Cobra and uh,
Tim,
Tim and Uri then got ready to,
uh,
to uh,
return home to get back into their soil use.
We got that hatches clothes.
They got in their space suits,
uh,
strapped into their seats and then undocked from the space station after their
six months day.
This was about three months into our state,
uh,
after their six months stay in,
they returned to earth.
So now for about three weeks there just three of us on board and I liken it to,
um,
it's a great time that when you go down to a crew of three have a little fun.
I liken it to when your family comes for a holiday and they stay for a week or
two,
you know,
it's a great day when they arrive and it's a great day.
When they leave
for that three weeks,
it was a very quiet,
the place on board,
the space station.
We just,
three of us spread out doing our own thing.
But the work continued,
uh,
both,
in categories of maintaining the space station,
running it,
repairing the things that break,
which were prepared to do a,
as well as the science and research that's ongoing.
In the meantime,
there are three others,
uh,
again at the Baikonur Cosmodrome and caustic stand prepared to launch after
they've completed their training.
And in this case,
we got a rookie astronaut Kate Rubens,
a first time flyer from NASA,
a rookie astronaut to Kusha to Kuya,
a Nishi Japanese astronauts his first time and then it totally over Nisha,
a second time flyer from Russia or Russian cosmonaut.
So,
uh,
I've given you a sense of the international flavor of this as well.
Uh,
among Cruz.
so two days after they launched,
they docked to the space station.
We got the hatches open and welcome them on board and they rounded out what
became expedition 48.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so that was in June,
I'm sorry,
early July of last year.
Uh,
and it's always fun to welcome,
especially rookies on board so you can share the experiences,
all the highlights and experiences of space.
We do a lot of science and research on board.
This is a shots of an example of one of those,
it's called spheres.
Um,
which is an acronym.
It's a,
it's a,
uh,
technology development program of a,
of a control system development for satellites and a w w it's been on board for
11 years now.
I think the first time I executed the spirits experiment was in 2006.
It's also used for student activities.
Here's another experiment.
Very a unique,
the,
this,
these are human heart cells grown from stem cells that,
uh,
and I learned for the first time that cells or heart cells beat at the cellular
level.
It's not the muscle tissue.
It's the cells that talk to each other.
Um,
and beat in unison to study the human body is a major category of the activity
that goes on up here.
And here's,
uh,
some shots of ELIC saying I participated in an experiment called fluid shifts to
better understand the impacts on the human body in that weightless environment
of space,
primarily to prevent or to Peru to produce counter measures for those adverse
effects.
So for future exploration,
we have a very unique facility on board the space station.
Uh,
and in the Japanese module it's an air lock that allows us to put experiments
and cargo outside,
grab it with a robotic arm and either deployed for long duration outside or
deployed from the space station itself,
such as these cube sets that were put up by the company name or racks,
uh,
which we pointed the robotic arm out into deep space.
And then they were commanded to be jettisoned a one or a pair at a time.
Uh,
so that's a,
an example of a deployable payload that you would have the potential to get into
and participate in.
Fast forward into the end of July now and it's time to receive another,
a space x dragon capsule,
which was launched from Cape Canaveral in Florida.
Again,
bringing up a additional load of supplies,
equipment,
uh,
and the new round of experiments,
research activities,
but also a very unique special cargo.
We called the international documented after which you see here being plucked up
by the robotic arm.
Uh,
that was to be attached at the very front end of the space station.
It also meant that Kate and I needed to get ready for two spacewalks uh,
to go outside because we needed to do a spacewalk to integrate that document
adapter.
I ended the very front end of the space station.
A spacewalk is definitely a highlight of the experience.
It's a long day activity,
getting ready to get out the door.
Uh,
and then we,
when we go outside,
we stay up for about six and a half hours is the typical plan time for a space
walk.
It's a very challenging environment to work in a,
it's physically and mentally.
It's the most demanding thing that we do.
Uh,
but it's also the,
one of the more rewarding things to do and memorable day memorable things to do.
Uh,
it's one of the thing obviously to be in space and the spacecraft,
it's quite another thing to get into suit and go outside and climb around the
outside of the spacecraft.
The a two space walks that we did,
one to integrate the DAC and adapter,
and then two weeks later we went back outside to do a variety of other tasks
were very successful.
Um,
and it was a,
that's one of those highlights,
Kate being the rookie on the crew to take her through that experience for the
first time.
And she did very well.
I'm very proud of her.
It also occurred to me,
space station has been flying along time.
Kate is just a couple of years older than my older son.
So we're,
we're on.
Uh,
the space station is a multigenerational program,
which still a bright future ahead of it.
Uh,
years.
one of the favorite places on the space station is what we call the Cupela.
I call it the window on the world.
This was integrated on the station in the spring of 2010.
It's the one place where you have six radio windows and then a center window
Sorta Lake,
a hemisphere of windows where he can see the entire globe from us.
Uh,
one vantage point.
so it quickly becomes a favorite place for everybody to go during their free
time.
And of course,
I took a lot of photography up there,
not only from the Cuculla,
but from all the windows.
I'm the space station to capture the details of the earth's surface.
Like this plankton bloom off the coast of South America or this horizon shot.
We see the thin atmosphere and then these beautiful cloud formations.
The Western us was central valley just right of center.
They're coming into view.
We see this a Sahara.
And um,
and the,
the place where so much has grown,
uh,
for food.
Here's a,
uh,
the largest coral reef in The Bahamas,
one of the most beautiful reefs in the world,
in my opinion.
Uh,
ice flows off the coast of Canada.
Early Spring 2016 last year.
Here you see irrigation circles in the river bed in the arid land around it,
uh,
in the state of New Mexico,
the southern tip of South America,
and the Patagonia ice shelves in the beautiful glaciers that occurred there.
And the rugged land forms around it.
Uh,
this is in the great salt desert sand domes that are called in your Ron,
uh,
very unique geology in the world.
Here's a shot of the horizon right after sunset.
So the orange is from the sun producing the silhouette from the weather,
uh,
in cloud formations are just absolutely beautiful,
incredible examples of what you can see from that vantage point.
Here are the elps and southern Europe.
I looking straight down through an 800 millimeter lens into the Grand Canyon and
the Colorado River here,
the Teton National Park,
the state of Wyoming,
very unique.
A shot of it,
what we call noctilucent clouds over the Poles.
Very rarely seen.
Typically in the summertime,
you see it over the north and our winter time,
see it over the South Pole.
But very mysterious formations.
We theorize,
or ice crystals and well above the altitudes that we see in normal.
When I relinquished the command,
and it totally takes to say that early September of last year,
and now you're getting the rhythm of life,
right.
Uh,
so we're at the end of our stay.
I hated over command to Anatolio Venetian.
Uh,
yeah.
he didn't enjoy it.
The time is spent together as expedition and 48 on the international space
station and that milestone began expedition 14,
nine and also mark our rate time to return to the planet that we call home.
So three of us said goodbye to the other three I got in our soil who's got back
into those space suits that we launched in strapped into our seats and prepare
to undocked from the space station.
The time from undocking to uh,
uh,
touchdown in central Kazakhstan is typically about three hours and 15 or 20
minutes.
So the whole process happens fairly quickly.
We undocked from the station,
fire the engines to separate to get a safe distance from the space station.
Then a couple of hours later flying over the southern tip of South America to
Landon guys extent.
We fired the main engine for little over four minutes.
That sets us up to now reenter the atmosphere,
literally entering in a fireball.
That's what you see looking at the porthole window there and experience it in
about four times the force of gravity.
And then the main parachute opens,
which I like to say is the most significant event of the entire flight.
Um,
and then you drift down under the parachute for about 12 minutes,
uh,
and touched,
um,
in what I like and to be a car wreck.
Um,
uh,
in central cosmic stand,
in our case search and rescue forces,
it's spotted as soon as the main parachute opened and they had a side of the
cap.
So within 30 minutes or so,
um,
we did some medical experiments there at the land,
each side along with the standard medical checks.
And then each of us got in a helicopter and flew about two and a half hours back
to the airfield that they were based out of.
And then my Russian crew mates got on an airplane and went to Moscow and I got
on another airplane here and did a three legs back to Houston and I was back at
home,
reunited with my family in Houston about 24 hours after landing in central
Kazakhstan.
Incidentally,
I earlier today I told the story about we all have experience of travel,
certain distances,
maybe even if it's around the block or halfway around the world.
We go on a trip,
we come back,
we might pull into a pull up in front of our house and we feel like,
oh,
we're home.
Or we might fly in from somewhere from another country
and land land at Chang.
And you feel like I'm home in this case.
As soon as the motion stops,
after you impact the ground and central Kazakhstan,
you get tumbled,
enroll,
and then you're hanging in the straps and you're feeling that relentless force
of gravity again.
You feel like we're home even though it's in the middle of nowhere and the other
side of the planet.
So,
um,
very interesting.
Um,
psychological detail I guess.
Okay.
Thank you so much commander Williams.
I just love seeing these videos each and every time.
It's just so inspiring.
Um,
so we wanted to get started by asking you a couple of questions and then opening
it up to the audience because I'm sure you guys have questions too.
So what I'm basing this on is some questions that were submitted submitted by
some of you guys.
I'm earlier.
So,
um,
since we are talking about products here,
can you list some examples of well designed products that you use daily in space
and were there any products that you thought could possibly be improved?
Just divide.
Everything we use can be improved,
right?
You guys work in the business where,
you know,
you got users
there,
you got developers and producers of products and then your users give you a
feedback and say,
hey,
we don't like this.
And if you've been in development,
you,
you or you do anything,
you put anything.
Nowadays I'm in social media and the Internet,
you get comments back,
right?
Not all the comments are positive.
So there,
yeah,
I mean,
we can always make improvement and everything and that's certainly true with
what we do.
Um,
it's,
uh,
you know,
there are a lot of moving parts to the operation up there.
Um,
and there's,
uh,
a great team of folks,
um,
not only at NASA,
but in all the,
the entire partnership,
uh,
that work
24,
seven,
three 65,
they're working all the time in mission control in Houston,
in the mission control in Moscow in a control center and Scuba Japan,
another one in Munich,
Germany.
Um,
and those folks are working all the details overnight playing in the,
the day's activities.
Of course they've been planning for months.
Uh,
but,
uh,
they,
they refine the plane right up until when we,
when we go to bed at night overnight,
uh,
they've finalize the plans for the next day.
There's a lot of details in that.
A lot of what we call ops products,
operational products,
just like procedures,
um,
and other,
uh,
resources that we need to execute the day's plan.
Um,
and overall we do a very good job,
but we're always in need of making that process more efficient and more
effective.
So that would be,
so I'm sure there are ways we could streamline a lot of stuff.
So how about a product that you wish existed that when you were up there,
what would you have loved to have that you didn't have?
The ability,
the ability,
that beam home for the weekend?
Actually,
I'm kind of a minimalist by nature and the,
I've spent my whole career in the army so I can eat a,
a ration and sitting in a foxhole in the pouring rain.
Um,
uh,
so there wasn't a whole lot that I personally missed up there.
I mean,
I went there like it was a,
it was going to be a trip where you don't have a lot of luxuries take for
granted,
but you know,
we,
we need,
uh,
we always need the equipment to do the job right,
to accomplish the mission.
So that's where the key comes in hot.
How can we improve all the different elements that are involved in accomplishing
the mission to make it more effective,
more efficient and safe.
So then let's touch on one of the points that I brought up with regard to
asteroid mining.
What are your thoughts on orbital vehicle assembly from asteroids sought sourced
material?
Well,
frankly,
I haven't taken the time to see what kind of material or um,
asteroids,
uh,
but just answering the question in a more generic way.
Uh,
let's say,
hey,
they go on to Mars for example.
Um,
you,
you mentioned earlier that,
uh,
we have to,
take a lot of things from earth.
We have to support it from Earth,
the space station.
You saw supply ships.
I'm going to go and continually just to supply and support everything that was
required to not only do the work on the space station,
but to purport to support the life of the crew.
We all eat every day.
We,
uh,
we breathe the air.
Uh,
that has to be maintained.
That all of the things that we take for granted here in the surface CD era,
uh,
that provide support for life have to be duplicated there.
So you have to supply that.
You have to sustain it.
You have to have the,
the,
uh,
the equipment that has the reliability and the performance necessary to do so.
When we go to Mars,
that's going to be orders of magnitude more critical because we won't have easy
access to send a spare part to send a replacement part,
uh,
to,
um,
uh,
compensate for a lack of performance or reliability and those systems.
So that means there's going to be a huge requirement to send a lot of stuff
ahead of time,
uh,
before crew,
whoever goes to get there.
Now,
if you can reduce that requirement of up mash of lodge and stuff from Earth,
if he can reduce it by tapping into whatever resources you find there,
and then have automated systems that can then turn those resources into the
commodities,
I indeed,
uh,
to uh,
do the operation on the surface and or provide the means to return to Earth,
then you've cut down on the recording.
Yeah.
And so that's actually one of the biggest expenses is moved the launch itself.
So this is where you guys come in three d printed space parts from asteroid.
I think about that.
Yeah.
I think that would be cool.
And we have a off the shelf three d printers on board the space station right
now.
So we're basically developing the operation,
proven out the operation that we can do it,
whether it be a design of something that gives up linked from the ground and a,
and the crew just supports the printer itself and,
and um,
and does,
uh,
the inspection of the product or if the crew's interactively designed something
on board.
But that's going to be a key component.
And that's a great example of Ben drawing from the raw materials.
So,
um,
we had another question as we often do,
about movies.
So,
which is your favorite space movie and which one is your least favorite?
Yeah,
somebody said gravity.
I got so many questions when that movie came out after in the weeks afterwards,
you know,
every time I had run into somebody and if they learned what I did,
well,
I would just see the movie,
you just see the movie.
I said,
no,
I haven't had time to watch the movie.
And I,
and I,
it was,
was that a three d movie?
I forget.
It could be right on a big screen.
Of course they had all the special effects and,
and whatnot.
Well,
I finally watched it,
but,
uh,
I'm going to disappoint you.
I know I saw it on a little strain on Singapore Airlines on a direct flight
between Houston and Moscow.
Oh.
Because I was going there for one of the training trips and I had,
I had other things to do,
but I thought,
well,
I'm going to watch this movie so I can answer the question.
Um,
so I mean it was entertainment,
although I gotta be careful because this is going out.
Right.
Um,
but you know,
I didn't have much of a storyline.
It had the,
and the guy at the beginning saying,
you know,
doing the space walk,
like you saw their individual flying around in a jet pack that we don't do that.
And of course the collision,
that catastrophe that they experience is nothing like a real physics.
So there,
there's a lot of liberties taken in that movie,
but I suppose it was,
it was entertainment.
So I would say,
uh,
I mentioned that one,
I'll mention the Martian.
Uh,
cause that it's another one that comes up all the time.
And I think I saw that one on an airplane to actually,
I haven't get to the theater very often.
Uh,
it was a actually a pretty good movie to watch.
Of course they did.
They took some liberties like you're always doing and movies.
Uh,
but it's,
uh,
it's one of those examples I think that,
can help the public be inspired about,
hey,
this is possible right now.
It might be science fiction.
And there was a lot of,
uh,
liberty taken in that movie.
Uh,
but this is something that's actually possible.
You know,
and,
and you can go back into this early is the thirties
that I recall.
And there were movies that were made about up people in space,
in space stations.
Uh,
von Braun had a great vision that was articulated through the fifties with the
help of Disney and whatnot.
And we are still in the process by the way of executing the vision.
He articulated in the mid fifties,
which was let's get into space,
into orbit,
lodge people into orbit,
build a space station,
going to the moon and to Mars.
That was his order.
Of course we did it in a little bit different order.
Uh,
so anyway,
back to the movies.
Those movies are fine.
The best movie,
if you want to know when I get the question,
what's my best space movie and which is the one I liked the best.
It's Apollo 13.
Cause they did an excellent job of telling the story,
a true story and uh,
tell him that in a way that was representative of the real world.
Uh,
so Apollo 13 is one that I really appreciate it.
Well,
yeah,
that was a good movie.
So I'll just say for me,
the Martian is my favorite movie because they made scientists look really cool.
But they also did take liberties because I'm,
when they showed JPL from the outside,
it was a shiny new structures,
stainless steel and glass.
And when you went inside they had all the sleeping pods and really cool places.
I had a World War II desk that you couldn't really open the doors on.
We had the latest and greatest in spacecraft hardware,
but this being a government agency,
the inside was not as shiny and I didn't know anybody who drove a Mercedes.
So,
um,
let me just ask one more question if I might before we open it up to the floor.
Um,
you mentioned the movie gravity and you talked about debris.
So I'm in the context of the ISS.
Um,
how does the station deal with debris and what kind of issues do you typically
face?
Uh,
well I think most folks are aware of the issue of space debris.
there is a lot of it up there.
Of course the,
the space is big,
um,
but there's a finite probability of,
uh,
at risk,
produced by the debris at the altitudes,
at the space station flies.
The larger objects are tracked and kept track of.
And if,
if the predictive models show that,
um,
an object or a single object is going to approach within a certain sphere of the
space station in advance,
we'll even do a maneuver the space station.
Okay.
Usually the predictive models don't pop up that,
uh,
that intersection if you will,
at Joe's too late to do them and over.
And then the crew will do a,
uh,
go into a safe haven,
which is the Soyuz capsule hang out in there.
So use captioning Jill,
that object dispatch.
So we prepare for those,
uh,
those,
real risks that are out there.
Uh,
but that's how we mitigate at least the larger objects.
And when I say larger,
those are objects than say like this just a few inches long.
It's the smaller objects that we can't track and we can't predict.
Uh,
uh,
and there is a finite probability of impact with a station.
Uh,
we have several emergencies that we prepared for him to space station and the
number one and the one that I think that,
uh,
um,
we need to take most seriously because of the consequences and the probability
of occurring,
especially when you consider the years and years that space station it has been
flying,
it will be fine is an impact by a small object which would produce a course,
a depressurization.
Uh,
so we,
uh,
developed the procedures to respond to that,
in all the crews are trained with the first priority of course the safety of the
crew.
And the second priority is to save the space station.
So we have procedures that would,
uh,
that would isolate the location of the leak and then isolate that,
saved the rest of the station.
So,
um,
I'm wondering if anybody in the audience might have any questions.
We have a mic up there somewhere.
Okay.
My name is uncle Lupita.
Uh,
I wanted to ask a question that when you're in space,
does your sense of time and perception slow down or does it stay the same?
Because everything is moving so slow.
The perception of time,
just like on the planet is driven by how busy we are,
right?
We can get bored and not be very busy occupied with things and it seems like
time drags on a,
but if we're under a lot of pressure to get some things done and we stay busy,
then it seemed like the day flies by.
Uh,
so you have the same thing up there except that we don't get bored up there.
We have the latter case,
uh,
because the,
the schedule is filled.
Now what we don't have,
and I think this might be what you're pulling that a little bit in the question,
we don't have the day night cycle and the cues of the Sun rising,
uh,
prompting us to get up to wake up and get up and get busy for the day and then
it gets dark again.
And we know shortly after that,
typically for most of us,
time to go to bed,
we don't have that up there.
We don't have those cues.
So everything is worked off the clock.
Uh,
so we've got,
um,
a look Oregon network spread throughout the space station with a laptop,
computers and I,
those laptop computers,
uh,
are many products.
One of them being the schedule for the day in each crew member has assigned
tasks to do with all of the materials necessary to accomplish those tasks.
And it's got a little vertical line across this window that has a schedule on
the vertical line is the current time and hit marches across the day's schedule.
So you find yourself chasing that light all day long to stay ahead of schedule.
Uh,
but it,
you're,
you're tracking,
okay,
wait,
what are you doing next?
And some continually setting the alarm on my watch,
uh,
to make sure I meet those milestones.
Now I'm pretty good now after spending time up there work and getting ahead and
stay in the head.
So my alarm was always going off.
Uh,
so that,
okay,
one minute from now I've got to be in the window,
the date,
take a picture of this term.
So that's what,
uh,
what I was dragging.
And we have those tools on board to,
to,
to predict.
For example,
when we're going to fly over at the precise second,
Singapore or anywhere else in the world.
So,
um,
you talked about the lack of day night cycles.
You guys orbit the earth every 90 minutes,
right?
Yeah.
So you're seeing sunset and sunrise throughout the day.
16 Times a day.
You can see a sunrise if you,
if you have the time to go to the window and watch it.
We have another question from the audience.
Hi,
my name is Jill from Google.
I'm curious to find out how you stay fit.
I'm not only physically,
but spiritually,
mentally,
all of it.
Yeah,
great question.
Uh,
physical fitness is very important that there be for obvious reasons.
We all use our muscles just to support our bodies.
Even sitting in chairs like we are right now.
Uh,
and when you're in a weightless environment,
the muscles don't have to do any work.
Uh,
so they will atrophy and not only the muscles,
but our bonds will atrophy as well.
Our bone strength and density of our bones,
calcium density is dependent upon exercise.
That's why exercise is so important.
It's emphasizes children grow up,
et cetera.
Uh,
so we have countermeasures on board.
We exercise every day.
Uh,
and we'll do aerobic and anaerobic exercise.
Your aerobics exercise,
uh,
includes running on a treadmill and you say,
how do you run on a treadmill without gravity?
Good question.
We wear a harness.
Uh,
each person has their own harness and then then we have bungees that,
uh,
are attached to the harness down into the treadmill.
We can vary the load and the speed of the treadmill.
And I typically ran for 30 minutes for four miles or so,
uh,
every day.
Um,
if you didn't want to run,
you could a cycle on a or governor,
uh,
and get your aerobics exercise that way.
In addition to that,
uh,
we had the equivalent of weightlifting,
we called it resistive exercise,
uh,
and we used the vacuum cylinders to provide the force that to replace a weights,
you know,
with weightlifting.
And,
um,
that is a very important counter measure,
uh,
to keep the main muscle groups,
the,
the core of our body
and support,
you know,
legs,
um,
and whatnot.
Back a strong and also to keep the bone density up.
Uh,
so,
uh,
every day we lifted.
Uh,
and then when it glued things like a body or a squats or dead lifts and then
other kinds of exercises as well.
So that was,
uh,
how we,
made Jane or fitness,
uh,
and the equipment we have on board now is very effective,
more effective than we had in earlier years.
Um,
and it,
it's,
uh,
does a couple of things that tells us a couple of things.
One is it a,
it tells us how important,
um,
the study of the human body is up there so that when we leave earth orbit,
we have the counter measures developed,
uh,
to,
to counter those adverse effects and maintain a healthy proof or the duration of
the mission as well as your,
the rest of your life when you get that kind of,
um,
uh,
and it also is a great example of what the primary purpose of the space station
that is developing those technologies,
developing the operations to enable us to leave Earth orbit,
uh,
psychologically,
spiritually.
I supported.
Of course.
That's very important as well.
Uh,
one of the primary ways that we're able to maintain our psychological support.
and we all can relate to this.
We all have relationships.
Human beings are relational beings.
We are,
whether we might think of ourselves as being very independent,
but we're all dependent and having relationships with others.
And it's important up there as well.
Uh,
in that respect,
you can get very isolated,
even though you're on a crew of six,
being separated from the family and perhaps more significantly,
we're up there.
We're very busy,
we're focused,
we're doing our jobs,
but our families are back home and,
and they,
uh,
for my wife in particular,
what I'm doing is completely out of her control.
So the endurance that she has to go through is I think,
much more challenging than what I had to go through.
A that requires support both ways.
Uh,
a key element of that support is just communication,
which goes back to the relationship.
So we have great kind of activity up there in terms of being able to make voice
phone calls once a week,
uh,
to uh,
assets.
Uh,
mission control in Houston.
We would have a video conference,
two way video conference.
So that was the one time a week that I could see,
um,
a friends and family from the ground.
Uh,
we also have the opportunity to make contacts with other friends and family,
uh,
throughout the world.
Uh,
limited.
Obviously we have internet connectivity,
very limited.
Uh,
you can't stream even audio on that kind of activity we have,
it's like the old dial up days for those of you old enough to remember that.
Um,
but we've got a team of folks on the ground that uh,
that helps support us,
uh,
in that respect and they do a very good job.
So we've spent a lot of time thinking through those requirements.
So I just wanted you to understand,
uh,
two questions I have,
what research or things you are doing on space station,
which can have immediate relevance seat will problem on earth.
So,
which she can solve on earth,
but we are doing something in space which we bring back to earth and solve a
significant problem over here.
That's part one of the questions.
Part of the question is if things start going wrong over there,
what are the things you have in place to correct them?
That suddenly things are going haywire on the space station.
So what are the measures you have to bring them back into control?
We train for years to prepare for flying out.
Take your second question first.
Um,
and uh,
much of that training it has to do with dealing with things that go wrong.
Something breaks as uh,
an emergency on the space station.
We have a oh,
a caution and warning Annunciation,
uh,
because some system failure or,
or what have you.
Uh,
so we're trained to respond to that.
The,
the minor failures that we have are covered by the redundancy and the design of
the system.
So you have a say a relatively minor and this is all relative,
right?
But something fails.
I redundance system automatically comes up and picks up the function,
uh,
where that system,
but there are other major ones where,
uh,
we can have significant failures where the crew has to get involved in and it
has to be trained to,
uh,
to respond to that.
Our mission control centers around the world also are key in that a response.
And as long as we have a telemetry and communication between the ground and the
space station,
they're there looking over our shoulders and,
and perhaps in many cases their prime and the response to it.
So we,
we trained for all the possibilities of all the things that might go wrong and,
uh,
we have the procedures in place.
Um,
and of course from the training execute those procedures.
Uh,
uh,
so I think that covers in general that the second question,
the first question,
uh,
a direct application where immediately it was applied to the ground.
That's a really broad question.
Uh,
we have,
uh,
of course what we call spinoff.
And you can go,
I'll point you to the NASA website where you get your,
somebody said you're two clicks away from the Bolivian,
but you guys weren't here.
We're here at Google.
We're all,
we all can relate to that,
right?
When you get out into the Internet,
there's so much information out there,
but you can find an endless list of,
of a spinoff technologies.
A lot of the things we take for granted that can be traced back either directly
or indirectly to space exploration.
Uh,
and then that includes the course examples across the spectrum.
a lot of the science and research that takes place,
it's like research anywhere,
right?
It's really hard to take a,
a specific narrow scope of research activity and say,
hey,
how does this make a difference?
You know,
out in the real world.
Well,
it doesn't necessarily make a difference tomorrow or the next day or whatnot,
but it contributes to a,
to a broader and a deeper body of knowledge that then it develops into a
technology or a capability that has a direct impact of the world.
So that's how I would generically answer it.
So,
yeah,
so I got a little excited there and interrupted you.
Sorry.
Um,
so one of the things that we do is we actively look at the research that's
currently being done to be able to build on it.
And the cool thing is this is all very new.
So anything,
any ideas that you come up with have not really been tested to the full degree.
So even high school students were able to put experiments up there.
One really nice example I like to think about is,
um,
so commander were referred to bone loss osteoporosis.
There,
um,
is a bone loss drug that's an injectable that's in common use.
Now they have $700 million of revenue a quarter.
It's,
it's crazy.
They're so successful.
But in order to test the drug,
they had to go through animal clinical trials.
And what they did was they sent up a bunch of mice up into space,
onto the space station.
And then,
um,
and before that,
even on the shuttle induced osteoporosis in these mice very quickly and then
tried the drug on them and they were able to reduce the time to market by
shortening the clinical trial period from two or three years down to something
like a three or four months.
So if you do the math,
you think about how much quicker it went to market,
that's a huge savings for them.
And that was the kind of thing that they could only do in space,
something that was not possible to do here on earth.
And there are lots of other examples like that too.
So as,
as as commander suggested,
you can go and look on the websites
when,
regarding what a recycling capabilities of a space station,
what can be recycled here or what needs to be brought from Earth.
And the second question is how do either,
so after you smell something,
it reached to your stomach because it's foreign because the gravity and ours do
need to do special maneuver for cause it to happen.
Actually the,
I'll take the second first and then hopefully I'll remember the first question.
Uh,
but your,
your ability to chew,
swallow,
all of that doesn't change up there.
So you could probably stand out in your head and swallow your food.
I,
I'm not,
I wouldn't recommend doing.
Yeah,
but it doesn't,
it's not impacted at all.
I will say that,
uh,
on occasion I've had a sense of heartburn.
I've woken up in the middle of the night with a sense of heartburn,
uh,
that might have been unique to the environment there.
But even up there,
it was very rare for me.
I remembered at Kareena my first flight.
I don't remember it after that.
Um,
so those functions stay pretty much the same.
So you asked the first question you had to do with recycling,
right?
Uh,
on the space station,
of course,
we're maintaining the atmosphere.
Uh,
and uh,
that means feeding oxygen into the atmosphere as it's consumed and our
breathing,
it means removing carbon dioxide is exhaled and builds up because he can't
tolerate a very high level of co two in the atmosphere.
Uh,
it means removing the humidity,
um,
eh,
that we breathe out or it turns into a rain forest shortly.
So you have to remove that.
Well,
all of those products that you,
you're either while removing,
if you can recycle them,
of course,
you and prove the closed loop efficiency of the system.
So we've got,
uh,
for example,
we read,
we recover all of the humidity.
Uh,
we recover the vast majority of the human liquid waste urine and all of that is
collected and put through a,
uh,
a process,
to recycle it.
And I,
I don't remember the exact number,
but I want to say we're not in the order of 70 to 80% efficiency,
somewhere in that range of recycling water.
Uh,
the carbon dioxide.
let's see,
some of,
I'm trying to remember what,
where we're currently at.
Some of that has dumped overboard.
Some of it is reclaimed.
We're adding technologies to what we were previously dumping overboard,
uh,
that where we can try to recover that as well.
And eventually,
you know,
you want to get too close to 100% efficiency as possible in the closed loop
system.
Uh,
we're not there yet.
and we have a long ways to go both in the,
in the,
in increasing that efficiency as well as increasing the performance of each
component of recycling and perhaps more significantly the reliability of those
components.
Uh,
access to space is difficult.
I mentioned that before,
but,
uh,
access to the space station to lower earth orbit is relatively easy.
So we in the space station is huge as I described.
So we have spare parts for just about everything up there and we can turn
something around in the ground and maybe get a spare part up there and within at
least a couple of months.
Uh,
but when we leave earth orbit,
even gone back to the mode,
access is going to be an order of magnitude more difficult.
And then when we go to Mars,
it's going to be orders of magnitude more difficult,
uh,
to be able to respond to a failure of a system or a loss of redundancy.
Or we won't be,
we won't have the capacity to take a bunch of spare parts.
So reliability system as well as the performance needs to be vastly improved
before to do that.
[inaudible].